my mom found help after she gave birth
to me oh my god which is four years
after their marriage
yeah like she said on the day of my
birth it's my birthday
right it was my dad's birthday too i got
i was born on my dad's birthday oh [ __ ]
and he goes it's also my brother's
birthday
you know she's like oh she didn't know
and then he was like i have this
twin brother he's in korea i've never
met him korean people do not know time
and place very
good you know how i'm in place let me
let me tell you something about
in five four three two
one what's up everybody welcome to
another episode of the genius brain
podcast i got one of my closest friends
here
at bart cheers once again ah it's almost
gonna be a new year
and it's dope doing podcasts with
friends because there's so much history
between us we get to talk about stuff
that
number one like i was just saying this
before that i know a lot of these
stories seems far-fetched but he's been
around for a good chunk
yeah like i've seen some of these
stories when he tells the stories
they're they're true
like even when he's telling stories
about me like that time after the motel
pool shoot
and i couldn't eat one bite oh yeah i
was listening to that yeah that happened
that was funny so you know so here's
here's a funny backstory of that so
this was so ed's uh
ed does video right and our buddy dan
does it too and we talked about this
before how we met we're not going to go
into that
so at this time we which i just didn't
have much [ __ ] to do
so there was a music video for this dude
named travis garland
right uh he at the time he was assigned
artists to my buddies um
the stereotypes right right they were
gonna shoot this music video out in
lancaster
and so lo and behold the star the female
star to this is none other than
at the time not very well known julia
kelly so if you guys know who julia
kelly is she's like the originator of
the fat ass pictures
so every every girl that has like a fat
ass pig you know give respect to julia
kelly because she was the one that put
her [ __ ] out there for you guys to
follow
the butthole thank you thank you the
butthole
uh uh blueprint is what i call it so
uh we had a very very uh another great
guy who was he was going to be the dp
uh dr photographer was brian right yeah
so brian
was hired on to be the director of
photography for this um
really dope music video it turned out
really great actually it's really
awesome
without him lip-syncing one word to the
song there's no lip syncing to it at all
and there's so many okay let's just
start with this right
so julia kelly was actually brought on
to the set
she didn't know who i was she was a
nobody at this time right
and at this point like i'm pretty well
known but
i don't really have much of an ego to
myself so i i just knew that don he was
shooting photos and i wanted to shoot
photos too so i was like hey let me just
help out on set i'll shoot photos
i still have those photos to the days
and those photos by the way are [ __ ]
fire yeah they were dope as [ __ ] i still
have them
um this is when i was really into photos
like i enjoyed doing it a lot so i was
like yeah i'll just do it for free i
wasn't even thinking about doing it free
it was just fun
so julia kelly at the time not knowing
who i am
or just people who who anybody was on
set she kind of had this thing of like
wanting to tell people what to do and
boss them around which i [ __ ] hated
right and she literally had like
she was like that girl on set that would
tell everybody to follow her on
instagram she goes
oh do you have instagram can you follow
me can you follow me and she was trying
to get to like ten thousand followers so
she goes i only need two more to get to
ten pounds because somebody followed me
which i already found to be a deplorable
just annoying habit or
this is like the early days of instagram
too right very early a few years in
yeah i didn't know anything about
instagram i just knew that i had a
following on youtube and this is what i
was doing
and so we weren't used to this you
you're telling me
what yeah you're telling me to follow
you what's wrong with you you know um
so before i even get into that so she
she comes in she gets hired for this
project to to to
you know do this whole thing with travis
so there's this pool scene
that's very important because the song
is called motel pool
yeah so she knew about this ahead of
time she knew what was going on
right and she gets there and she looks
at the pool she goes it's too cold i'm
not going in
we've been there for [ __ ] like what
18 hours so yeah
shooting a so such a long time
and it got to this point where she's
like no i'm not gonna do it i'm like
excuse me this whole thing was for you
like we did
the money is already spent we're here
right so she gets into the pool
we're ready to shoot her scene by the
way will take at max 10 seconds that's
all we ask for
10 seconds can you do this and she said
yeah she agreed and she goes water's too
cold
i looked at her i remember i walked up
through because i was pissed at this
point i was like you're an
actress act like one i was irritated for
you i was irritated
because she was causing such a scene
over something that she agreed to and it
was based on her
and this shoot at this point was
probably like at five in the morning
yes right because we also needed to
shoot a sunrise
so we scheduled it to start to shoot at
like 11 p.m exactly
at this point like this is the money
shot the title of the song
motel pool well to make it up to you we
had to do makeup shots yeah and we had
to go to another pool to shoot and it
was also freezing cold so
we stood that's how we finished all
those pickups that's crazy yeah
it wasn't all there at there and then do
it again
and she did it credit to her at least
she did yeah she did a great job
yeah and then the funny thing was like
and i'm pretty sure she's a really sweet
person now i follow her or whatever one
and i'm not saying she's a bad person
right
and uh there was another uh viner at the
time
not in a viner at the time uh leanne v
yes they were best friends i'm not sure
if they're still best friends now but
they i don't know i don't know their
personal relationship
but she was telling me like no she's a
really sweet girl like she's just you
know
she's young she just doesn't know what
she's doing right all right cool so we
gave her a pass
but once again not knowing i'm
she kind of like treated people who are
helped very poorly which i disliked
so i remember this because when we were
wrapped up and we're going to do the
desert scene
where travis is following her through
the scene right she goes hey can you get
my bags for me
[Laughter]
she looked at me she goes those are my
bags and you get them for me and i
looked at her and i was like
what i did i remember exactly what i
said i was like that's funny
your arm's broken or something she was
like
what i was like i'm not the help right
and i walked away
and so this is a funny this is the
funniest part about it i'll give a [ __ ]
i'll tell this story
so you know travis he's he has like a
he's like flirting with her she's very
hot
you know she's very beautiful woman
right he's flirting with her whatever
what now they're doing their thing they
have a make-out scene and
whatever yeah there's a part where we
have to
pack up and leave and there's only a
couple of cars that have seats my car
and travis's car right so we're all
about to leave and then trav you
see travis off in the distance thirsty
as [ __ ] julio
i remember this you remember this right
julian
you know and then she looks at me she
goes can i get in your car go nope
that's true guys yeah you guys keep
accusing him of these fake
is travis good [ __ ] luck dude yeah
and that's where it goes off
where we all took adderall because we
didn't sleep
so so check this out so back in the day
me ed and dan used to pull all-nighters
24-7 all the time
we just couldn't sleep we're insomniacs
you know we're young
culture yeah we're still young now you
know so but we we just
just didn't give a [ __ ] we used to play
smash brothers we used to drink we used
to just party this is what we did
but this was a pretty taxing shoot right
very limited budget next to nothing
yeah and it was a fun project that we
all got to do problem with that is when
you have
a low budget means you have to get a lot
of shots within about two to three days
and so within those two days we didn't
sleep at all 48 hours
no [ __ ] sleep in the middle of a
desert this
there are so many weird splotches that i
don't remember but dan told me i don't
even remember this part
i took like six red bulls to the point
where he said like dude you were just
doing stand up at a certain
point oh my god yes you don't have it i
don't remember that i was
[ __ ] dying that's that's what i
remember the silver lining about that
shoot was this like little moment where
don went to go get food and we're just
sitting around waiting
and you were just improving
and going off and you put on this show
in the motel room
and we were cracking up dying we were
just like yo why aren't you
doing stand-up more often dude like
you're killing it in that room of like
what uh eight people yeah you know see i
don't remember doing that part i was
just so delirious but you know i just
stand up since i was 16. so
that skill is always going to be there
yeah you know but dan was like you were
making people
die laughing word you were i was like i
wish you recorded that because i don't
remember any of those jokes no
no you know what i remember i pulled out
my phone you stopped oh really yeah
that's why i was like yo you're you're
killing it man yeah
you know at that time too was when i
kind of stopped doing stand up as much
but you know i still have that that want
to still do it every now and then you
know
and i always write stand-up sets till
this day yeah so that ability once you
do it when you're 16
like and you do it religiously that yeah
that ability is still it's not going to
be as good as before
but it's still always going to be there
yeah like video was my [ __ ] i started
when i was like 15.
it's always there it's that's yeah when
i quit and i was just doing groceries
you know i i'll make little skits here
and there by myself yeah you know and
and and part of it being like part of
who you are i couldn't run away from it
either
so i just was like okay i'm not a video
guy anymore i am doing
this now yeah amen like everybody needs
advertisement
everybody needs propaganda everybody
yeah
and anytime ed and i did a project
together it was always because it was
fun
you know it wasn't really work you know
you always did
dumb stupid [ __ ] i just remember
just on set is one of the most fun times
you get to have because
you're [ __ ] around yeah and i think
that was one of those things about even
doing back uh before i was working with
you i was doing uh
justin's oh yeah just all those funny
sketches and it was just about
how dumb can we be here every week how
absolutely stupid can we make this and
you know what people kept loving it
yeah and it was fun that way because it
was a freedom
yeah you got you were creating for
yourself first anyway so it didn't
matter if people
i mean it of course of course it hurt if
people didn't like it but at least the
the motive was right there so you were
happy with the result in the work that
you did
yeah you know and so when we were doing
this um
lancaster music we were all delirious
and obviously
so ed at this time me and ed are both
fat as [ __ ] right
so this is like the funniest [ __ ] so
there's in lancaster there's this random
southern restaurant right
that there's uh louisiana food right so
like etouffee
gumbo you know a fried catfish whatever
by the way
probably some of the best like uh new
orleans
like south that i've ever had right and
it's out in lancaster right
and i've been to like you know going to
new orleans
we did it together we stayed a bunch of
[ __ ] food but you hate seafood so you
suffer
right that's another thing so there was
this one moment and you know what when
you look back at it
the moment is funny but it wasn't as
funny as it was supposed to be
because we were hopped up on adderall
haven't slept in 48 hours
so this is what we're all [ __ ] eating
and
he did the oddest thing this whole
finishes all of his food right and there
was his one chicken bone with like a
little flesh left he goes
[ __ ] ed looks at us and he goes bro i
can't have another bite and he shoves
his bowl to us
we're that's completely empty
and then i really wait okay and then dad
goes
ed what the [ __ ] there's no food in this
bowl
no no okay i my my previous
nickname from dan was technical ed okay
because i'd always go technically yeah
technically
or actually my dad didn't say that [ __ ]
yeah and that was me that was me being
technical ed
i was like look there is literally one
bite on there
on that bone literally and i cannot
eat it anymore so i'm going this is what
i mean
why are you guys laughing at me what's
wrong with you guys
because this one couldn't understand how
[ __ ] funny it was
it made us laugh even harder so i i was
getting angry i was like
yo what what why are you laughing at me
yeah there is one piece of i can't eat
another bite
he was getting angry so it made us laugh
even harder
and so you know till this date that is
the hardest i've ever laughed in my life
and it is literally the hardest i've
ever laughed because of the delirium
and growing pains right i remember he
was so upset i was like
why don't you understand why this is so
[ __ ] funny because it doesn't help
that he was so fat
yeah yeah so it just made it even
funnier i just remember
my face my jaw was sore the next day
but check this out so this is the first
time i ever did adderall
uh dan was an adderall abuser because
he [ __ ] would never stop working and
he would edit all night now this is
before he built his company he had other
people editing under him
he did everything himself and it was you
you and dan yeah so
i didn't know exactly what adderall did
right i didn't know that it made you
hyper focused yeah so
one of the things that happened was you
guys were ahead of me and i was
following you guys right
i skipped the exit by like six exits you
were just
looking at the lines i was just zoning
looking at the lines
and everybody was sleeping and i just
remember driving and i
moved i went like 10 miles past k-town
i just kept driving and next thing you
know uh i forgot who woke up they're
like how far away i was like
oh [ __ ] i was like we're in santa monica
i was too hyper focused but that that's
why i think i was a little delirious too
like
um so i went to a psychiatrist when i
turned 30 right
because i was like i can't focus i
always suspect that i
had like 80d of some kind and i got
diagnosed with it
actually it was pretty severe yeah they
prescribed me first with like 15
uh milligrams of like adderall and then
um it didn't work for me right yeah
still like
yeah and so okay bumped it to 20. and
then they changed the brand to vivants
was pretty much the same thing hello my
friends have you heard of better help
listen it's time for you to take care of
your mental health i am a huge advocate
of mental health and
people you go to the doctor to heal your
body so you need better help to heal
your mind therapy was not something that
was talked a lot in my household so
getting the mental health that i needed
especially because it wasn't emphasized
when i was younger
was something that i didn't know that
was necessary in my life and i have been
so
much better for it listen better help is
more affordable than traditional offline
counseling and financial aid is
available
i want you to live a happier life today
so try better help and give it a go
because you deserve the best version of
you every day
visit betterhelp.com genius that's
better
h-e-l-p and join over one million people
who have taken charge of their mental
health with the help of an experienced
professional special offer for genius
brain listeners get
10 off your first month at
betterhelp.com
genius that's betterhelp.com
genius to get 10 off your first order
that's b
e t t e r h e l p dot com
slash genius it's an amphetamine
yeah and then they bumped it up to 30
and i was like i cannot focus on
anything i tell them it
i just feel high you know and it like
because i told him i was like look
i'd done molly before when like yeah
this is it's like a
slight version of this so this crazy
[ __ ]
doctor said now that i'm thinking about
it now he said
so you open up the capsule
put it in a cup of water and then you
let it dissolve
so it's not no longer time released and
it was 50 milligrams
of advance of an amphetamine and he's
like
let it all dissolve and then take the
shot
and see how it does for you and
bro between cocaine
and like yeah ecstasy bypass it was the
same [ __ ]
oh wow yeah it's it's it's like it feels
the same i was just
hot i was at work how did you feel it's
like i got nothing done yeah
i got nothing done to at the same time
so i reported back
to the shrink i was like yo yeah 15
milligrams doesn't i still can't focus
and then that's when he was like talking
about the spectrum
for the first time for me and but he
didn't like diagnose me or whatever but
that i just knew that i have
a very high level of like adhd
so between adderall cocaine molly
and ecstasy they're kind of the same
yeah the way i feel very similar
feelings
yeah i uh i definitely have a form of
adhd and the way i balance it out is
hyperactivity i have to
do you work out i work out bike i have
to do excessive [ __ ] if i don't do that
i'm [ __ ]
like i'm right i'm [ __ ] i can't sit
still i start like
shadow boxing in my living room i start
being antsy that's why i got that sit
stand desk so when i edit i stand now
because if i sit i lose my mind just
even the just
having the ability to move your legs and
wiggle around a little bit
helps me rather than just which you know
i wish i knew about this when i was
younger because i
would have done way better i say the
same thing every time especially when
i'm
like with a therapist or shrink i wish i
knew this when i was looking
yeah like if i see my kids struggling to
and i see the same
stuff that he has he or she has the same
uh issues that i have i'm like you're
gonna get a sit stand desk
we're gonna put you in jiu jitsu karate
martial arts whatever do you do you
recall a time when you're a kid where
you're like huh i wish
there was like a something for that like
you recognized that was like kind of an
adhd no i just thought i was dumb
i just thought i was an idiot you know
i'm like what the [ __ ] are these people
so much smarter than me no no i believe
that about myself too yeah
because my parents treated me yeah they
don't know our parents don't believe in
eight no korean
adult believes in add or adhd yeah my
mom to this day does not believe yeah so
you know what that is no you're just
satania
yeah you're just a lazy yeah it's a
legend it's a devil
yeah it's just like if something's wrong
like that's another thing i grew up
thinking
something's wrong with you something's
wrong what's wrong with you what's wrong
with it why are you like this why you
like this
now i know too it's just you know
there's this uh
people tend to or maybe our parents like
an older generation
they have this set formula that they
think is going to work for everybody yes
and then you find out when you're older
that's never the case but for them
i think they just want to believe that
so hard and this the work that it takes
to
not believe that and to research and
figure stuff out is way more difficult
than just pressing this one belief on to
your kid that
something's wrong with you you can do
what these other people do rather than
saying oh there's something different
about this kid
let's figure out what works best for him
right you know like to say all humans
are the same
is way too simplified right so
uh what i was explaining the whole point
of this story was that when i
turned 30 i was like 250 pounds i was
fat as [ __ ]
and uh i had a doctor check out all this
[ __ ] and i was just
whack i was i'm gonna die by the time i
was 40. yeah
and um so the antidepressants
or anti-anxiety medications didn't work
which is why i lost the where i started
losing the weight so i was like maybe
i'm [ __ ] because i'm fat yeah right
all right so let's do that and and i
dealt with the weight loss which is
where i'm here now
and sadly adderall still doesn't work
yeah you know um yeah it is a definite
thing board now it has to be more
pragmatic practical
behavioral things that i have to do to
make this work like you said
like uh being active and um standing
desks
and and constantly finding yourself a
rhythm to get through this [ __ ]
yeah or else it's chaos things are such
it's hard to that's why i'm i'm
surprised i even have the minimum amount
of sense i have now because i'm
with trash bag that's why when i look at
it when other people when they're
unsuccessful i'm like
you don't even have the [ __ ] i have
what's wrong with you right you know
like
it's hard like it's it's difficult like
having to deal
like people i actually edit all these
podcasts myself you know and let me tell
you something
when you have [ __ ] adhd is different
oh well shout out to you i thought ray
did it no i did this [ __ ] well david
yeah when you're watching this back you
know and you know the hard part is is
that
i had the best experience doing the
podcast but i can't listen to it back
because i've already experienced it
right
you know so but as i'm doing this i have
to make mental notes because there are
certain guests that sometimes they say
things that i don't think will make them
look that great right because they think
that we're having a regular conversation
and i have to delete it out because it's
not a it's not a clear representation of
who they are as a person right and it's
out of context it's like don't you hate
when chinese people
i was like hey they say you know and
it's not
anything too crazy but it's more like i
know the the cultural milieu and i
understand how people will perceive this
stuff even though i know what they're
saying
but because there's no context it makes
them sound bad and then that's where i
have to delete certain things
right because i don't want to have to go
through comments and be like listen this
is why you're [ __ ] done this is what
they meant
you know so i i have to do that so i'm
always taking like mental notes but
usually people are pretty good with it
and
i always give people a heads up i don't
really cut things out too much so just
be smart about your [ __ ]
right because i want it to be a natural
conversation but uh when we were talking
about parenting you know
ed has a very it's such a weird story
like i don't even
i always say this with him it's like how
do how do we even begin because his
dad's story is
i want to make it into a film to be
honest with you like i i really do
because it's it's so unique right like
we in the previous podcast we talked
about uh ed's him finding out his dad's
involvement
in kk which is korean killers which is
one of the original og korean gangs out
in los angeles
and if you talk about korean gangs and a
lot of these asian gangs the reason why
a lot of these gangs started up
is because people were bullied right you
know people were punked
and it's like yo there's there's
strength in numbers
and this is how a lot of gangs actually
start up right where they got sick of
being pushed around being punked
and so they had to develop this aggro
type of personality and this aggressive
group to make sure that nobody [ __ ] with
them again and this is like the
onslaught of like how kk started a lot
of these asian gangs you know
i um i had to do a lot of things so like
when you first met my dad he looked like
a
frail probably like 80 year old man
right so he thought he was my heart with
you right
when he when we went to go pick up his
dad at the airport and i saw his father
and this is actually not too long before
he passed away
uh i thought it was your grandpa
i was like oh you're picking up your
grandma from the airport yeah you know i
was like oh it's good that your
grandpa's gonna see your grandma cause i
met your grandma already before
and they're like that's my dad i was
like oh [ __ ]
shocked yeah well um
at that time he was like he was 52 years
old that's [ __ ] insane dude you know
he did not look 52. younger than my dad
because
he had a very wild life a
very very wild life growing up
um and
there was a time where like i get a lot
of the stories like before i i talked
about how my mom always gave me the gang
talk
don't join the game don't join a gang
meanwhile i'm like you know i i don't
think i'm gonna join any gang around
yeah
what are you talking about why are you
giving me that talk
and what i was realizing is like uh as i
got older i learned more stories about
my dad
and about a month before he passed uh my
son judging in with him and then i just
asked him i was like what's your story
yeah
tell me the full story what's going on
what's up pretty much the best that i
can
piece together is that uh my dad was
born
a twin right i don't know if you noticed
this have you ever met
someone your dad's age that's a twin
why is it that our parents generation
and our grandparents there are no
twins yeah yeah i don't know anybody
who's a twin that's an old generation
there's superstition
they get rid of them oh really old
shamanistic
kind of thing you know uh
with twins and [ __ ] like a i don't know
i don't know what it is it's it's
something [ __ ] up where they split him
or
whatever yeah yeah
yeah so i i don't know the whole story
but it's just you don't have twins
that's why i've never seen
somebody my parents say that's a twin
you too right yeah
i don't know a single one so um
the thing is my biological grandfather's
older brother
he's young his wife my harmony
is barren she doesn't have kids and so
he had twins so he gave you know
pretty much my dad for adoption to his
older brother
which is my harabaji you know and he was
a military man
he was in vietnam as a sergeant uh
because when when
america went to vietnam they they're
like hey remember how we helped you in
world korean world yeah
we need your help right so they they
sent a bunch of korean soldiers to
vietnam yeah
so that's where my height which was and
um
at basically this is this is the story
my
mom said when he was 13
they sat him down there like you're
adopted
you have twin brother we're going to
america
he never met him wow and they bounced
and they came to
they came to l.a i came to what was in
koreatown
then you know this is what
1977 seventies
by the way you have a twin you're never
gonna see him and we're going to america
yeah like what the [ __ ] man
and now he's in this vicinity of what is
to be
koreatown in l.a you know and he's going
to virgil high school
and this is what i asked about his life
coming to america
when we were eating jajangmyeon and he
was like um
i was i was actually 16 years old not
13.
they put me in the seventh grade you
know because he didn't speak english so
he's the biggest oldest dude
in the 7th grade class what the [ __ ] and
then he's a grown-ass adult
yeah and he just said he just [ __ ]
everyone he just beat everybody up
all these little kids he just said he
just beat everyone up because he was
you give a [ __ ] he was angry he's just
like people they treat him like trash
for being korean and all that [ __ ] and
remember how i told you when i acted up
at my school the teachers didn't do
anything
yeah i think he had the same story
because he
stayed there like he's getting bullied
you know what's he gonna do so he said
he was in high school
and he's already the biggest guy in
school
you know because he's way too old to be
in high school
yeah but then more korean immigrants
started coming
he told me and they understood him
but they also under came from a korean
high school remember chingu
yeah his captain so my dad saw himself
as cat the first one
yeah virgil right so this other korean
kid
comes in and he said he actually
challenged them to fight even though
they're the only two koreans
oh my god how great is that [ __ ] that's
so he just come first thing he goes
let's do this what do you i just got
here so my dad
he said at the rallies and assemblies
he sat on the top row and he wouldn't
allow anyone to sit on the top row with
him
and if they came to sit with him he he'd
beat him up
and so he would sit there by himself on
the top row
during assemblies and prep alleys right
and this other korean kid comes in
and he said he sat up there with him and
so he
beat him oh my no explanation and no
explanation and then from then i think
and then they became best friends
and then only them two sat on the top
row that's
so [ __ ] funny dude your dad is a
volatile human being dude
yeah and so he started telling me like
on on vermont and olympic you know
where it's loco and the gas station
exactly where that is and he's he was
saying those were different plazas
different things different gas station
and they said
the korean kids in high school that's
where they
meet up that's where they all gather
yeah and then they'll do their fight
club they'll
smoke cigarettes they'll [ __ ] around
they'll go look for the triads they'll
go
little tokyo you know oh my god
and and pretty much that was the start
this is like
he said this is like late 70s kind of
thing early 70s holy [ __ ]
yeah so i didn't know
my dad was up to any of this [ __ ] yeah
my mom would never tell me this she
would just tell you not to join gangs
yeah like from my perspective my whole
life i just grew up
like living my life and then all of a
sudden my dad like i'm going to korea
for the first time
and i'm 15 years old and
uh i i'm at the airport
and this is before 9 11 so we're saying
bye you know at the
at the terminal you know and i get on a
plane fall asleep
get out i'm in [ __ ] incheon and my
dad
is there on the other side wow in korea
this podcast is brought to you by
raycon my friends are you listening to
music or podcast with wired earbuds well
my friends
you might as well just go back in time
and stay there since you like to use
outdated things wireless earbuds are
the best and raycon wireless earbuds are
right there
among the best my friends with seamless
bluetooth pairing and a comfortable
noise isolating fit you can start
listening right out of the box and keep
listening
for hours audio quality is amazing and
comparable to what you get from other
premium brands except raycon
start at half the price and i know
people
love good deals out there and they love
good quality well raycon has both that
and i've been listening to raycon
earbuds
for quite a while when i go on walks
specifically when i'm biking because
they're super lightweight
and i love the noise isolating fit so
raycon's being generous for the holidays
so on top of their everyday great prices
they're offering my listeners 15
off right now go to buy recon dot com
slash brain today to get 15
off your raycon order that's by raycon
dot com
slash brain that's by raycon dot com
slash brain my dad's twin brother
oh [ __ ] i
i never met this guy barely heard about
this guy
and he was shocked to see me because me
and my dad are like you look like twins
twins like literally a carbon copy of
your dad yeah
so like who the [ __ ] does ben look like
dude
what the [ __ ] he looks like there's a
hybrid between between us
yeah but like so in in my perspective
i'm
getting all this information later in my
life
because they kept all this stuff a
secret like long-lost twin brother
adopted cake like yeah you know
all this [ __ ] and it made me understand
why my dad was the way he was
yeah you know [ __ ] up life yeah very
damn i'm sorry that's not good
it's on very um
i can see where he
he felt a lot of like abandonment up
obviously because as a as a twin
or not only that like where
his brother has a family and all that
stuff
and all he ever knew was just my hard
working harmony he didn't know any
cousins he had any
siblings it was just him who did he
leave to
the states with yeah just my harmony
so just his so okay so his dad was
around though
yeah yeah um but i know
i my harabji was scary too
oh okay one thing about my heart was how
i remember that he was scary he was
militaristic
and like even the way he made my dad
cower was scary
but he was full of love he loved me like
a whole lot
and i i don't understand why but he did
you know
and that was the first
like even so it's the first time i saw
my dad cry it was my when my head was
you died
oh never seen that you know but
check this out this context we're at the
funeral
right and my high energy and i'm my dad
is crying for
i've never seen my dad cry ever yeah and
i have adhd so my leg is shaking like
crazy right
tell you what i'm like only five or six
years old then my
my crab my crap my dad
slaps me in my leg [ __ ] heart
squeezes it he's like
yeah i started crying yeah and everyone
thought i was crying for my heart of a g
but i was in pain because your dad just
[ __ ] tiger clawed your own place my
dad thought i was being disrespectful to
my head of achievement by
twitching my leg so then when i say my
dad is a gangster like
he takes no [ __ ] yeah i'm a six-year-old
kid and this is what he does
you know yeah so like i grew up under
this household where it was
like
you know somehow i'll [ __ ] you up which
is why when like
the [ __ ] that happened to me at my store
people are like
dude why do you get yourself in that
situation like don't you get
scared like my dad is scary
yeah you know well there are no eyes
there were a lot of situations like that
so
i remember uh dude this is one very
interesting moment where uh when i was
in seventh and eighth grade there was
this kid that i
that i uh he he held this grudge for a
long time and i've told this a million
times here but it's this kid who i
stabbed in
like third grade and then seventh and
eighth grade we went to the same junior
high
well lo and behold what three four years
he still held that grudge
uh he decides to jump me at the the bus
stop right
i remember i got jumped by him and a
couple of his homies and
you have to realize that uh when you're
in seventh and eighth grade and a
seventh and eighth grade kid hits you
and you just got your ass beat by your
parents with like a metal bat
yeah and a lead pipe yeah you guys being
beating you with a belt and kicking you
to the floor
getting hit by a kid didn't really hurt
much right and so i remember this kid
socked me in the face and he i got
socked and i looked at him and it didn't
do anything and i remember i just
i remember as a 13 year old i just had
this moment of
that didn't hurt you know and i just
chased after him this fool just ran into
the bus stop and went into the bus so he
couldn't get his ass beat
but there's these things where you get
your ass beat so hard by your parents
you kind of start to wonder like what am
i scared of yeah this didn't hurt at all
yeah it's okay yeah i think that's
part of that i don't know if it's a
a poverty thing yeah poor people
poor people kind of deal with their [ __ ]
right
um yeah like when
i said previously when i would get in a
fight and i'd lose
you know my dad would flip his [ __ ] it
was
he was so disgusted at me that i would
lose a fight yeah
not like not like hey you know
clean me up none of that [ __ ] no
coaching
just he goes where do you sit on the
bleachers
yeah exactly like on the top who's your
best friend yeah he probably thinks i'm
on the bottom run it looks like that my
dad
disappointed me yeah look me up and down
that way
um a lot of times and which is why
for me back on the on the school ground
i was like
i better do something yeah you know
or else you know and that's what where i
got [ __ ] up where that's pride
that's proud moment for my dad you know
he was so proud of me
when i go okay so like the month before
he died
me and my brother tigs of course takes
yeah
after uh my friend joe's uh
wedding and we went to tiggs
and we're out just smoking cigarettes
chilling outside
and there's this this guy your size yeah
pretty much but he's a like straight up
fob you know and he's drunk it's his
birthday
and he's drunk so me and my brother
we're just having our conversation
and all of a sudden i'm looking at my
brother and i see this giant head
grab his collar right and he said yeah
shibashiki and i see my brother look at
him like what the [ __ ] because he's
a huge guy yeah he's tall he's drunk as
[ __ ] yeah he's drunk as [ __ ]
and so i jumped on his back
i jumped on him and i put a rear naked
and then i just yanked my ass back like
just yeah
pulled back as hard as i could and then
we all three of us just
fell over and all of a sudden it was
like seven thumbs be
versus me and my brother yeah and
long story it was a scuffle my brother
[ __ ] that giant dude up yeah
like he he put him out like yeah he put
him out
size difference was pretty amazing but
regardless of that
the next day like we're having lunch
with my
my parents and i told that story to my
parents i was like
like because my brother's hands all
bloody and scrapey yeah his parents said
what's happened
and as i'm telling this exact story to
my dad his smile is just oh my
god i've never seen him so proud of us
in our life but that was the last moment
i had with my dad
that's hilarious but it just really
explains like
who he was and what he sees valerie is
valuable right yeah
and which is why i'm
i'm not always afraid to get in some
[ __ ] despite my size
yeah because of the pressure i was under
because my dad meanwhile while trying to
be a suburban night now
yeah was still raising me under some
like
like gangpet [ __ ] yeah that's hilarious
dude it's like hey dad remember when i
graduated college with the degree who
the [ __ ] cares you remember that one
time you beat the [ __ ] out of that giant
korean dude at the bar it's like exactly
oh my god hoppa please my parents didn't
come to my
graduation that's funny like they didn't
didn't
they don't like coming to my recitals
for trumpet or any of my [ __ ]
whatever um it was like that and there
was just like
there are things especially
accomplishments where he doesn't give a
[ __ ] about
but if he cares about something that i
did that he cares about then
that's versus like was your dad like was
he very omnipresent in your life growing
up or was he
at least around a lot
he'd be he'd be mincing chunks at a time
okay yeah uh
and like this is why i love my mom
because i look back and i uh i uh
when you're a kid you don't realize what
your mom's doing
like when she's damn near a single mom
for sure and there's three [ __ ] kids
yeah you know um
there are times when he'd be gone and my
mom took care of the rent to carry the
food still took us to church
what's your dad doing when he was
missing who the [ __ ] knows
yeah bro whatever kang pistol could do
you know
i'm sure i've looked around where like
he took taurus pictures and [ __ ] let's
see like times square
it's like wait and i was alive then
exactly yeah it said like
94. like huh
where were we we were alive um yeah and
um
your dad just just he wasn't ready to be
a parent
he got married when he was 23. i asked
him this actually
i said oppa you know why'd you get
married
i just asked him straight up why did you
get married yeah
and they said that's the only way i can
get out of the game
it's the only way it's okay for me to
leave if i got married
then they'd let me leave and he met your
mom
and he met my mom and he didn't leave
oh told me that god because on the other
half of the story my mom
was like he's would be missing at the
tangujang which is
billiards yeah you know or any of that
[ __ ] and so
he'd be gone all night and the thing was
he
at the time he bought my mom this
pontiac firebird with the phoenix on the
hood
oh [ __ ] yeah yeah that was her car like
and so she'd throw us in that car go to
k-town
look around for his car you know and he
had us
like this seven series and so she'd find
the right tango junk
and she we're like two or three years
old she'd leave me my brother at the
door
and bounce knowing that my dad was there
to cause him to come
oh your mom is a [ __ ] gangster dude
that's the thing too
like i forget that my mom got saved at
40 years old
she became a christian at 40. sometimes
i forget that she's a summoning in this
yogi business yeah like like sometimes
oh you want to [ __ ] around here's your
kids you got to come back home damn your
mom's a
thug dude yeah and which is why she's
okay being out there still she's fine
with it
yeah she can handle it she calls me
sensitive she always calls
you're too sensitive that's why it's so
sensitive
yeah she's like okay i mean you're not
wrong but yeah geez
my mom's pretty like rough around the
edges too like i remember when
my very first girlfriend she dumps me
right
and uh i'm like
i'm like back home from college and i'm
uh in the room and i'm telling my mom
i'm crying right i look at my mom
and i go well she's like why are you
crying and i'm like i just got dumped
for the first time right
and i'm like just don't tell dad right
i'm crying and then she goes
she she comes up to me she puts her hand
on my shoulder and she starts rubbing my
back and she's just like
only [ __ ] cry like this
she's like chunk beer it's like
you're embarrassed she's like
like basically what she said is like
it's like [ __ ]
about
the door and when she called me that i
just started crying more i'm like
because she's like calling me a [ __ ]
you know i'm like yo this woman is the
most insensitive person on earth and i
literally told her
um don't tell appa she goes oh don't
worry five seconds later my dad comes in
so you got dumped
i'm like you know she might i told you
don't tell him anything and my dad's
just like trying to console me but he's
not even consoling me he just called me
a [ __ ]
yeah you know it's so same story my
first
first girlfriend dumps me and i don't
know what to do but
call my mom yeah
and then she was like she's talking me
through here here talk to oppa like oh
no
wait what who of all last person on
earth
for a second i'd rather i could talk to
anybody
and i said he just goes why you cry
why yeah listen don't be the stupid
be the happy okay i'm like
oh oh that okay i'm better now
don't be the stupid okay that's so funny
that's like the probably the moment that
your dad was like i'm gonna be a good
father
he tried his best hey
don't be a gay
you're like a gay huh
that's so [ __ ] my dad actually called
me out for that because i was wearing an
abercrombie shirt
i ever got me a polo god and at their
their sleeve
was the first to be super short at the
time and yeah you just call me like
gay good morning gay boy
it was a gig that's so [ __ ] funny man
your dad is such a weird like color so
when after you guys left to
seattle right because you guys you guys
were in k-town and then you guys left to
seattle yeah
um why did he go back why did he go to
seattle in the first place
well maybe there's some legal things i
probably shouldn't talk about
which is why at first um
no but we uh
we we lost everything after the la riots
oh yo after the riots
we had a kongjung and
we lost everything like
just looted it down to the bone you know
and we just lost everything so
we're starting over and my mom's older
brother oldest brother
lives in federal way and that's where we
lived for like a few months till we
found our own place
yeah but pretty much um
that's how i ended up out there like
from la all of a sudden to
the [ __ ] middle of nowhere dude yeah
and
yeah it like my dad
just looking back the way i read run my
store
i think my dad did the same way too even
uh i remember i'd be in seventh eighth
grade stalking [ __ ]
and then uh i remember this guy's like
yeah you're dead he's a good guy
you know like um oh my dad all right
yeah and then i i asked my mom so what's
that about
and she's like oh the other day some two
guys were beating that guy
up and then you know so
you know i play baseball my dad stole my
[ __ ] bat
right and he kept it behind the counter
apparently he ran out there and beat the
[ __ ] out of these guys with my bat
you know and save this dude you know
and so my dad would go out and do that
[ __ ] at least
for for his friends and for his people
yeah
like he's violent but he's righteous
that's every korean person you know what
i mean like these
these like weird violent spurts you know
what i look back to and i understand why
people think some of these stories are
very far-fetched
because when you look at the prototype
of a human being that gets into
you know fights and brawls and [ __ ] it's
not somebody who looks like me yeah you
know like i'm a very sweet like jovial
looking guy
but you guys have to also realize like i
wasn't born here
i was my first language was korean i
looked the way that i did
people wanted to bully me but i'm also
very very korean
like anger and all this other [ __ ] was
the first
uh first i first thing first way to
solve a problem
yeah anger and violence so it just kind
of seeped into my every being and i
think that's why i got bullied a lot was
because
of the way that i looked and then it
stopped the bullying stopped so much
when i got older
because i would fight back so much right
because it's a very korean thing to do
you know like you can't just do that you
know like you would just die on your
shield first before you let somebody
make you a [ __ ]
right and so that's just kind of the
mentality that i had and it's like it's
stuff from an older generation my dad's
a super nice guy like my dad would never
get into confrontation but
he would always instill this in me
though it's like make sure that when
you're bullied
that they remember never to bully you
again yeah like
you guys got to realize too i'm not
really telling telling gangster stories
as much as i'm telling korean behavioral
correct exactly
this is all this is like that it's hot
it's that's a ton
it's yeah um the internal eyes just like
you can't step over me don't you [ __ ]
dare step over me yeah and i think
you hate being capitalized meanwhile
it's also capitalizing on top of other
people
for your own protection sometimes yeah i
mean it
i i had to really think about this
because a lot of the bad business
dealings and a lot of the bad projects
that i've gone through was through with
korean people
and i think it's it's like what is that
you know what i mean and i had to sit
there and think about it i was like why
why do these people all have a very
similar trait and
it's like they all have this scarcity
mentality kind of thing you know
maybe it's left over from the korean war
yeah or something like that but they
always had this thing of like well if i
could [ __ ] somebody over to make me
better i'm going to do it because it's
about me yeah and also
who knows we could lose all this it's
like hey um it's not the korean war
anymore
yeah you're not in school you don't have
to [ __ ] in a hole anymore yeah you're
you're good you're good
you know you know but yeah like that
that
like i'm not going to say hoarding it's
almost like it i'll get me could be
yeah but then um yeah a lot of it is
what we were talking about earlier why
it clashes with
a christian culture as well yeah when
we're all koreans
and we're also christians that's why
previously we were talking about like
all the trauma that happens when
religion and
culture clash dude i remember you
telling me the story about your dad just
like hoarding all this [ __ ]
saying like this is for you yeah yeah
yeah what the [ __ ] is he talking about
that's that's where i
i was so like perplexed in
in his mindset about why he's doing all
this
kind of thing like and it was always
some gangster mentality like
um i've told this to you uh i
my dad went to prison when he was 21
fresh out of high school you know that's
right on some burglary charges
and um so he's not like
he's not supposed to own a gun but he
kept the gun
of course you know and
and that's what got him in trouble the
second time later in his life
when i was like [ __ ] 20 years ago
uh i'm a junior in high school and i get
a phone call
and it's the sheriff like who's been
working with the fbi
and they were staking out my dad what
the [ __ ]
because he was having some walter white
[ __ ] operation
going on out there in seattle
yeah let's just say out there in the
state oh wow
wow
what and
yeah um so that was one of those things
like i'm i'm 16
and this is when you're older yeah yeah
yeah
and now i'm seeing this happen my dad's
my dad is a kung fu you know straight up
like it's not just stories like this
it's not just stories yeah
you know and which is why when i said my
dad can beat up your dad i'm like
i [ __ ] mean it will literally kill
your dad yeah
so i'm like so
i'm going through my senior year without
him uh which is why i didn't come to my
graduation
yeah you know all this [ __ ] which
was a lot of the things that i
had to learn especially even when he got
out now he has a prison mentality
you know now now he's a gangpet prisoner
mentality and it's this was like
sharpening your guys's toothbrushes and
[ __ ] it's like
it's like you don't need to do this i
don't know just in case yeah
and i mean it hurt a lot inside the home
dynamic
too especially for your mom because your
mom's like who is this guy like
you know probably the you know i mean
obviously he was
he's like kind of like devolving right
because he's probably already bad enough
as it was he was like gangplay in the
beginning and now he goes to prison now
his prison mentality it's like oh
like what is happening like i told you
how like i found out of my my dad's twin
brother
my mom found help after she gave birth
to me oh my god
which is four years after their marriage
yeah like she said on the day of my
birth it's my birthday
right it was my dad's birthday too i got
i was born on my dad's birthday oh [ __ ]
and he goes it's also my brother's
birthday
you know she's like whoa she didn't know
and then he was like i have this
twin brother he's in korea i've never
met him korean people do not
know time and place very much you know
how i'm in place
let me let me tell you something about
my parents right i
remember this [ __ ]
so i have a it's me and my older brother
right
and uh we're sitting at the dinner table
and we're just having dinner having a
good time just eating right
and uh out of just nowhere
i [ __ ] you [ __ ] not true story i'm
just eating having dinner or whatever
and then my dad goes
hey you know what's interesting you were
supposed to die when you were born
[Laughter]
i stopped i look at i'm like what do you
mean
i was like well your mom wanted to abort
you you know but i said no which is why
you're alive so thank you to me
and he just starts laughing and i'm
sitting there why would you
say that to me right and it's like well
your mom you know she aborted like three
other kids before you so you're supposed
to have like
like three other brothers and sisters
and i'm sitting there just
what the [ __ ] is going on what there's
no segway to this conversation why did
you say this to me i don't think korean
americans understand
koreans are perfectly okay with
abortions yeah
like go to korea yeah they're perfectly
fine with it yeah you know and i'm
sitting here just like shocked and she's
like yeah you're supposed to have like
two other
my dad's laughing he's cracking the [ __ ]
up and i'm sitting here just mortified
like you're gonna board me i'm like
why would you say this you know my dad's
dying laughing and
i look at my mom like oh my is that true
she goes yeah but you know you're dead
you want to have another kid
what the [ __ ] are you saying right now
you [ __ ] jackasses
man i think like one of the things like
when when i went to korea to see my
oh by the way uh my dad didn't meet him
until they were 50 years old
way later wow yeah you know your dad too
i could it's funny because i could
i saw a a
shell of the human being your father is
when he was at 52 which
he his death looked like he was in his
80s yeah but i saw the older picture of
your dad your dad had a thick ass
[ __ ] neck dude yeah this [ __ ]
was yoked he was
your dad was yoked dude like holy [ __ ]
it was
literally cheek then neck yeah you know
yeah
i mean and even like uh genetically
yes what is this called trap your trap
yeah just i don't work the [ __ ] out and
it's big because of my dad
yeah my sister has to do it she's like i
hate this
but yeah he was a big guy and he just
and on like i said on top of that he was
always older than everyone else because
he came to america very early
yeah and and so he was a chip on the
shoulder kind of guy
but also like didn't have a whole lot of
faith on me
at all either you know yeah well he
he had an idea of what a man was which
was a very trashy idea what a
man and a human being was and you
weren't living up to that expectation
but at the same time this is the weird
dichotomy
of the han what you were saying earlier
because i was so stupid i couldn't make
it out in
you know in seattle go to university or
whatever
so he started teaching me to run the
store because
i should stay here and run the store
yeah like him
yeah [ __ ] but meanwhile calling me a
pyeongchang
idiot
[Laughter]
that's what my mom would call me growing
up yeah
and so uh
yeah the idea that a parent could call
their kid a [ __ ] [ __ ]
is so normal though right it's like oh
yeah my mom called me that too yeah
like the korean language if you ever
wanted to learn how to curse
or get mad in a language korean language
is the one to do it
my mom used to say this phrase to me
like when we get she'd be upset at me
and my brother she would always say this
phrase and it's stuck with me she goes
what that means is like she literally
called me a dog's dingleberry
the [ __ ] that hangs from her yeah
exactly
you [ __ ] dog dingleberry [ __ ] is what
she would call
it because she would get so mad it's
just kareem is the
the best cursing language yeah but yeah
uh
like back to it well my dad
always felt like he was disparaging me
his end game and
end goal was to make me successful in
the worst way possible right
which is why when like this garage is
just
full of all these tools and
junk and [ __ ] and whatever it's just
like
questioning like what is all this [ __ ]
for it's like this is for you
don't you i'm gonna this is like handing
this down like thanks mufasa
yeah it's like the pride lands
and it's just a bunch of garbage yeah
really but it was like all he had
yeah it's all he got he's left and i'm
looking back at it like this
he his home was korea like his favorite
movie was chingu
watch that [ __ ] every year i love it
because for him it was like high school
that he didn't get to have
yeah he had it in [ __ ] america but he
played by those roles in america anyway
when i used to when i watched uh chingu
right uh i never thought it was like the
dopest movie ever and i was like what if
life was really like that i remember my
mom told me she goes
that's how it was what do you mean she
was like that's not made up
that's how it was in korea like you had
the older hyungs and they would run [ __ ]
like a [ __ ] gang
and you would have the younger people
running around doing your bidding and
there was kangpes
inside the school and they would take
that [ __ ] outside you know some people
some people ended up not doing it when
they were older but it just continued on
and even when they stopped doing it you
still see that type of relationship and
behavior of the hyung and the hyundai
type of stuff
even after they grew up and they stopped
doing that [ __ ] yeah i didn't know that
dude i so when i went to korea to see my
my uncle and you know in korea like you
grow up
with the people you grew up
all the way up you're in the same
classroom right
so i'm visiting my uncle we're having
dinner and he brings his friends and
um i see them they're holding hands
they're in their 50s
you know and they're holding hands by
their pinkies and swinging their arms
that friendship
[ __ ] is real it's deep out there yeah
but you don't already [ __ ] [ __ ] up on
there you're wearing a [ __ ] polo when
he calls you a [ __ ]
[Laughter]
exactly it's like papa you're holding
pinkies with that guy
he's
you know your dad is so
they're so weird it's hard to figure
figure them out their
their life and their relationships with
people were so complicated it's hard to
understand from our perspective
which is you know like i've always
wanted to tell my dad's story mm-hmm
and i know you know if there there's a
story in there where you and i still
relate too
yeah to my our fathers even though we're
way past the generation and tons of
technology and all these things like
we can't help but feel the way we feel
and it reminds of
us of how our dads react to yeah
you know and it's just every time i do
something and i think about the time i
was pissed at him when i was a kid for
it i'm like
all right like you understand
that's why when we mentioned too about
like
asking your parents to understand you
when you don't even know their story
it doesn't make any sense because nobody
does things just because is what i'm
finding out there's a reason for it
there's a reason why people do
the things that they do and they behave
the way that they behave like i
understand why my dad
was so particular about family stuff
right
and my mom told me to pity my father
because she was like you should feel bad
for your dad and i was like what do you
mean
and she goes the hardest thing about
your dad is the fact that your dad
didn't get to grow up with a solid
family
right he was kicked out in the street by
his own sister his own family your dad
you're your grandfather
his father went bankrupt and he had to
fend for himself he had to live in a
hotel
motel room um because his best friend
parents owned a motel in korea and they
allowed him to live in the room yeah so
this is how he survived so all he wanted
was a really tight-knit family but your
dad is so socially [ __ ] awkward
he doesn't know how to communicate with
you guys so everything that he wants to
do he's destroying
he wants to be close to you he wants uh
this this single unit family where we
live in the same house together
but he's so awkward he doesn't know how
to talk to you converse with you that he
pushes you away
so imagine how sad that is for your
father everything that he's doing is to
live this dream of a tight-knit family
but
his behaviors say otherwise so it's
destroying his personal dreams he goes
you have to understand how sad your
father i feel bad for your dad
like i feel terrible for him because he
wants to
have this relationship he doesn't know
how so you know i
empathize with my father a bit like he
he grew up
not knowing that the hardcore family
love that he wanted to give to us
but because he didn't have that in his
life he doesn't know how to express it
so it caused friction between me and him
you know story of my dad's life
not knowing exactly how to express
himself without
[ __ ] [ __ ] up yeah they're like
destroying everything that they're
trying to create
you know and it sucks yeah because all
they know is is a whole lot of
self-destruction
yeah you know um and i i see my debt
and then i my mom had that talk with me
too you should pity yeah
like under what he's grown up in you
know
and i understood that uh at least at a
young race that i
can't hate my dad i cannot
hate my dad when i was like 15 it was
like my mantra
i don't know why it could have been the
christian aspect of it
yeah but i'd constantly thomas don't
hate up i don't hate apple don't hate
alpha
you know and i'd even have to sometimes
tell sora
don't eat up don't eat appa and i don't
exactly know why but i think it was just
a christian thing but in the
end it gave me a lot of peace when he
passed
because yeah i didn't hold the
resentment
against him for being
like who he was well he was yeah because
he is he just
is i can't say he's a bad father or a
good father he just
is he was my father and that alone is
enough for me to say i love him
yeah i think that was like one of the
things that maybe i didn't i think that
your brother and your sister never
came to terms with right was that they
saw your father
the exterior of your father right they
saw all of his
his actions and they judge him for that
and i think the difference between you
because it's also a coping mechanism for
you is to understand
he is who he is and he tried his best so
how can i knock him for trying his best
and we have to also look as we're adults
now too if i had the same situation it
would have ever turned out better
and i guarantee i wouldn't have a
hundred percent i probably wouldn't have
you know i think that's the hard part
too is like as as kids
we we kind of want certain things from
our parents
right and when we don't get it uh
especially in your case when your father
passed
um you're trying to not have hate in
your heart
you know yeah you want to because how
does it help you cope
how does that help you deal with the
fact that your father passed and not
having this relationship that you
thought you wanted
yeah you know and i think that's the
that's the difficult part of
being an adult and uh accepting that
reality
right because it's easy to hate somebody
it's that's the easy one that's so easy
it's it's the very quick quick way to
deal with it [ __ ] you out of my life i
don't want to think about it
um but i think it's easier said than
done when it comes to a family member
like your dad
you know and it was because of my faith
at the time where you know my dad like i
said gangpet growing up guess what he
got saved when he was like 45.
that's crazy you know yeah because uh he
just got out of prison
all this [ __ ] and you know we put him
through church and whatever you know
he got saved they beat up the pastors
[Laughter]
dude my dad has written the bible five
times over
wow like he's reading it and he would
write it
he really really like i can see it's a
religious aspect of it you know
like but he was really trying to atone
for the past 50 years of his life yeah
he was really trying to make things work
and for me i wanted to let him know
like he that he is loved he definitely
didn't feel i can tell he didn't
it's probably because he felt he felt he
[ __ ] up so much yeah and you know
so we'd have phone calls and whatever
he's like yeah go to the
costco and pick this up okay i'm like
okay
i love you up uh yeah i could hear him
go
oh okay get choked up because i i never
we never i
i don't i don't know why i just thought
i'd just tell him i love him yeah
and the last time i saw him too same
thing after we got that big brawl that
ticks
i i you know went to goes
and i was gonna leave i was gonna head
back
here to la i gave him this hug
and he was a [ __ ] skeleton yeah
it was like yeah i told i love you same
thing and he goes
yeah like he doesn't know how he's like
you're gay
he starts crying the other day
but i had my i got my peace at least
yeah
do you think that your other siblings
got that too over time yes
yeah it was just a little harder for
them yeah yeah
for me it was because like i didn't go
to university yeah
you know you probably spent i was like
yeah
you know after my dad went to prison
my junior year my mom sat me down and
says don't sign up for
college yeah don't apply you're staying
at the store
jesus that's what i did yeah you know
wow you know especially if you're an
asian american growing up
and all your friends are getting into
the uw was like the pit like
outside of the ivy leagues everyone went
to uw
and mom was like don't even apply you
know you gotta run the store
and and
yeah i'm sorry that's all good my um
my parents didn't think much about me
but
i was stuck the thing was i was stuck at
the store
and i was around him all the time yeah
and he was really mean yeah after prison
is really cruel was what he learned in
prison yeah
and he said he said a lot more hurtful
things
than ever before he got way more
like aggressive aggressive and wild
i remember once just he had a mouth full
of pop in his mouth
just she screamed at me pop is flying
everywhere that's how much he didn't
give a [ __ ]
you know but
i don't know i always let him know i
loved him
i mean do you i think that's like the
missing piece that maybe your other
siblings didn't have is that you
actually got to spend time with him
you know and you got to see him at his
worst but i can only imagine what your
dad was going through
you know probably like emotional turmoil
like he yeah
you know obviously he went to jail for
the whole walter white situation like
that that whole meth situation right
and he won't even tell me like exactly
what exactly he was doing yeah
and that's the thing too it's like i
don't i don't personally know him but i
feel like
at that point you're at that age your
dad is doing stuff
to make ends meet you know to make sure
that he could provide this
specific life for his kids because a lot
of asian parents too they
one thing that i know that is a constant
and a lot of these like immigrant asian
stories is that
a way that asian parents showed love was
by showing how much they could provide
right and imagine the the type of stuff
your father was going through knowing
that he was doing his best and he was
probably making good money doing this
stuff
and then he goes to jail loses
everything comes back and he's back at
square one
and he's dealing with his own personal
demons at this point so he's not even
yelling at you he's doing it himself
because he hates himself
you know yeah then i could tell that i
can tell he was really ashamed
of what he had done yeah especially as
we're older and we all saw him
get sentenced so
and in the end too my dad still ever the
kang pe
you know he tried to be like mature and
sit us down he's like
do you know you know like if you have
any questions you can ask me
you know tell me ask me why
you know so i asked him okay why did you
do it
yeah he looked me and he's like because
i wanted to buy you a car
wow yeah you [ __ ]
you know and the funny thing is is like
he's trying to provide you
things the stuff that you didn't need
you know it's like
and that's i didn't need that
i needed you to be my dad yeah as a
freshman or no i was probably a
sophomore
in college i was driving around in a 750
il
v12 wow and he put 20s on it
i didn't ask for any of that [ __ ] it's
like edward you want to be rapping
you want to be you know it's a ride on
this at 20. my dad drove the same car in
the 80s
that's hilarious so he got the same 1989
car that he used to have
for 8 000. that's the crazy thing too
it's like i i appreciate that about your
dad though that it's so funny that
his self-destructive behavior was out of
selflessness which is insane
you know that's what i'm saying it's
like when we when we have these
conversations
about empathy and understanding other
people
it really does help you put these puzzle
pieces together
right because when you don't understand
what's going on it's very easy to get
into anger
but when you have an understanding of
the whole picture and you start piecing
these stuff
up you can see the whole picture and it
helps you understand what's going on it
helps subside that anger a little bit
because one could say hey well [ __ ] your
dad you know i mean he didn't give a
[ __ ] about you or you or your mom and
the kids he just wanted to do his [ __ ]
and make money but that wasn't the
motive if you never had that
conversation with your dad
if your dad never said hey ask me what
uh yeah what this was for he goes i
wanted to buy you a card you're like
what the [ __ ]
and look at him so matter of fact about
it straight up and he told the truth
like it you know he just wasn't a liar
yeah
and he said it like it was so
and that's why at this point like
imagine if you just lied to me and i'm
sitting here wondering
why he did all this [ __ ] in my life and
based off
what he told me because i had a few of
those moments with my dad where i
remember he brought up like
um he he basically told me he was kind
of upset that he didn't do well in
school it's like some stuff that he had
resentment towards me
right he goes i gave you everything to
be really smart in school
then education and everything else he
goes do you remember in high school and
i told you that if you just got straight
a's i'd buy you a bmw and i remember i
looked at it right this was like five
six years back i looked at him i was
like
who the [ __ ] that i wanted a bmw you
never even asked me what i wanted
i didn't want any of that stuff right he
goes you could have had a nice car
that's all he was thinking it's like
young kids want nice cars so i'm gonna
do this for my kid but he never had a
conversation and asked me what i want
yeah and he was like
and i told him i was like you know what
i wanted from you i just wanted you to
support me
i don't give a [ __ ] about all this other
stuff when when
teachers were telling me i wasn't either
smart enough they were telling me that
i was problematic i wanted you to be on
my side but you never did that for me
you just kept on saying oh i'll buy you
a car i'll do
[ __ ] all that [ __ ] i wanted you to
support me i wanted you to tell me that
i could do stuff outside of the store
but you never did that for me you kept
on providing something that i didn't
need
yeah you know and it was it was almost
like he was a robot he was like short
circuiting
he goes i did the best i could i did the
best i could which was the only thing he
could say
i did the best i did the best but it's
hard because i think as an adult and i
would be hard for me too as a parent for
my kid to tell me i [ __ ] up
like oh [ __ ] and i can't take this like
back look you don't understand
in 1989 you gotta go back there emw
you got it you know yeah
you know so i'm glad i had these moments
and i you know even now
too i know uh specific korean people who
haven't had these conversations with
their parents
and their relationship with their
parents is very sad it's for me to watch
because they don't understand who their
parents are because they're still angry
at them like they're that five-year-old
kid
they're not coming out from from an
adult's perspective and so when i see
them still fight with their
50 60 year old parents about [ __ ]
and i'm like
you you don't you still don't get it
you're not gonna change
yeah they're not going to change it's
been 60 years the only thing that you
can do now is talk to them and try to
understand where they're coming from
because you're just going to lose your
[ __ ] mind there's no point they don't
have a willingness to change because
they don't have a problem with how they
live they did 60 years of it why the
[ __ ] would they change down in their
last 23 years of their life
right you know it's hard which is why to
this day i have to keep telling my mom
i'm doing bible study
while she sees this [ __ ]
you know um but yeah like even
just looking back just about how they
tried
they [ __ ] tried not to say my dad was
a total piece of [ __ ]
he quit drinking for a long time you
know
that's about it i'm just kidding no no
no
but no we we were [ __ ] in
abject poverty after the riots though
yeah like
i skipped ahead and i said we moved to
washington but we were actually in flint
michigan for two years
yeesh yeah and they bought a
a two-story three-bedroom house for ten
thousand dollars because nobody wanted
to live in that neighborhood
you still did it now yeah and the people
still don't want to live in flint yeah
you know
yeah i lived there and it's where i got
this car my brother has his car here on
his lip and
you know the reason why we moved out of
there because
it was it was rough yeah and [ __ ] but
yeah like we lived in such poverty that
they shut the water off and and the
power
and there was a good while where
for a month we we all had a
piss outside and really hold our poop
until we got to school
dude that's crazy because the toilets
didn't work yeah and so
my dad's friends would come and donate
big jugs of water to us
so we can flush the toilets as long as
you can dump it in this double it'll go
down yeah
guess how we took i guess i thought we
took showers man
yeah but i remember too like when um
like our we couldn't like fix our water
heater and [ __ ] and then my mom would
have to like boil water and
like stick it in the tub exactly and
just to heat it up and those things were
so normal to us because we didn't
know any better right like i can't even
share some of these stories with other
people they don't know what's going on
like to them they're like well you lived
in some [ __ ] but when i was a kid
if you don't know anything else it's
just life
it's like oh this is life this is like
91 90 no 93
yeah you know 30 cent tacos taco bell
yeah sometimes i always wonder why i'm
so short
i think it was yeah nutrition-based
honestly
my brother was telling me i think it's
nutrition-based can your mom cook
no see that's probably a problem too no
because my mom could cook you know my
mom could
make nothing into something you know so
it's like
one thing that i know i that for my life
anyways growing up is that we always had
good food
i mean it wasn't like new food every day
but you know my mom would make a big
batch of soup or whatever
yeah and then this was the food that you
would eat so it was a like
you know kimchi for one week i had the
taco bell mcdonald's experience
because it's so cheap those hamburgers i
wanted that [ __ ] though
because they would never buy for me
because they're like you have chivas
you know but that's the hilarious thing
about why i look at poverty today and
like why
people who are in poverty are obese
because it's actually cheaper to eat
that [ __ ]
cheap food is the worst for you yeah you
know
best example i hated beef growing up my
whole life
i hated eating beef i didn't like the
taste of it i didn't like any of that
[ __ ] well until i had like a medium-rare
steak right i'm like oh this is
a difference yeah yeah same yeah i was
like what the [ __ ] i don't know
well done beef yeah you know a lot of
asian people eat well done beef
and so i remember um and i hated
mcdonald's too i hated eating mcdonald's
but then when you're in college you're
broke as [ __ ] you don't have a lot of
money
right and then you would have these 25
cents cheeseburgers and [ __ ] like this
20 cents 30 cents cheeseburgers
and that's when i started liking
mcdonald's but that's up because it's
all you've had that's all i had you know
that's all you have and then you just
get a dick to itself yeah
i gained 40 [ __ ] pounds you know and
i became addicted to this food but
that's why when uh when i see people
they're like oh why don't they just buy
healthier options you know how [ __ ]
expensive organic food is you [ __ ]
it's hella expensive there's a reason
why people buy canned foods and frozen
foods
is because it's easier to deal with it
doesn't spoil and you can feed a lot
more kids that way
and i could see it so like i'm i'm 34
now
my dad was 34. he had all three kids
yeah they were in flint michigan
that's crazy and i gotta imagine just
like
that would suck that would [ __ ] suck
but they did it man somehow can survive
this i don't know how
yeah and up to the point where we got to
lower middle class
you know and that's why i
still don't try to take anything away
from my dad but i also know he probably
didn't feel like it was enough for him
either
you know because what he quote unquote
used to have of course kkk and all that
[ __ ]
he 100 sounds like somebody who was
comparing his old self to his new stuff
you know you see him
he probably sees himself getting
physically weaker um
yeah yeah so while i'm getting bigger in
high school
uh we're [ __ ] around he wants arm
wrestle and i beat him
after that he made me do so much [ __ ]
physical labor
just made me carry heavy [ __ ] all the
time and sometimes it'd be
for no reason and then at one point and
like
i was just like is he jealous
and even my mom pointed out like even
with my camera gear
he gets jealous so i was like this
gunpet you're a father this [ __ ]
gangster [ __ ]
can't move past the [ __ ] yeah yeah
so that was the dynamic i was growing
under so it's like
support for anything yeah
like i don't think he really gave a [ __ ]
if i had a's at all
yeah at all it's like oh you think
you're smarter than me now
because he didn't finish high school
yeah you know that's so funny he's like
he wants you to do better but he hates
you
at the same time so you go to a that's
good go die
think you're better than appa it was at
one point in high school they
my parents didn't even look at my grades
anymore where i was like
getting away with this dude you're so
lucky my parents were looking my grades
knowing that knowing the terrible
outcome
because you know what's going on looking
at my brothers and sisters oh really
they gave up on me
that's hilarious i wish my parents would
have gave up on me dude because my
my dad was like where's your report
caught on my oppa we know what's gonna
happen
you know what's on this report card you
know it's not a good that's what i mean
so they were just like
grooming me to just take over the store
it's just my test like
someday this is yours this what it's all
you
dude that's so crazy but it was all but
think about
everything he'd lost and everything he
built
i mean to me it doesn't mean [ __ ] but it
is
from where he had you know flint
michigan and going through the riots and
having this and being able to like
support a family
it's pretty good yeah yeah that's why i
i don't take anything away from my dad
because he worked his ass off and
i see myself when i feel lazy um
or depressed or whatever like my dad had
those days too
but what i mostly know him for is
working [ __ ] 16 plus hours a day
yeah every [ __ ] day that's the thing
too when i look at it and i'm like
there's a reason why like i worked so
hard in the beginning
you know and i'm still working well i'm
not working as hard as i used to let's
just be real
like i got tapped out a lot uh but
i don't i appreciate what my parents did
but i also don't want to live the life
that they did yes
working until i'm like 60 or 70 years
old right you know um
but i also had this conversation
recently too where i'm actually very
glad i
i grew up really poor because
it gives me a different perspective and
lens on life and it allows me to thirst
for more because there was so much i
didn't have
you know so these experiences that i got
to experience as adults isn't stuff that
i got to experience with another kid
because we didn't have the means for it
but that's why i appreciate travel so
much so i appreciate these things
and so sometimes i see a lot with these
kids who were born in wealth they're the
most boring [ __ ] i've ever been in my
life
they need so much stimulus because they
had everything everything was handed to
them on this [ __ ] silver spoon
so the way they view life and how they
need to get stimulus
it has to be through extravagant [ __ ]
which is not stuff that i really need
you know yeah i i think one of the
i guess there's a lot of downtimes about
growing up poor for me yeah for sure
but um i definitely see it in a lot of
the
you know once again going back to the
suburban church
group when you're seeing around and um
where they're trying to relate with me
about the uh
like the stuff that's happening to me at
the store with all the racist [ __ ] that
i talked about in the past
and one guy's like dude
someone at work said you eat kimchi
and i was like yo what the [ __ ] shut up
that's it you do it kimchi yeah isn't
that a fact
yeah and so i
i'm thankful for like at least i'm
a bit more aware aware of where i can
focus my attention and my feelings
yeah you know through seeing the worst
and
experiencing maximum pain you know
early on or so many times you know it
does give you thick skin
but not the kind of thick skin where
you're just like unable to empathize
yeah but just really be like hey man
like it's not that bad you'll be okay
yeah especially with the younger kids
today like saying you eat kimchi is
pretty racist to them
yeah like they're they're i don't want
to call them soft it's just a different
generation but from what we had to grow
up with right
so you know with them it's just that's
why i always get very particular
about people who always want to call
everything racist you know
and sometimes when you do that it's
going to sound like you're just being a
little [ __ ] and people aren't going to
care about real problems and real issues
so it's like well [ __ ] if i if you're if
anything that i say makes you mad that
i'm just gonna say whatever the [ __ ] i
want
and it gets to that point for a lot of
people yeah like when um
uh like i see a lot of these what's it
called tick tock
tick tock videos talking about their
form of racism and it's like
that's not even that person being racist
they just don't know any better they're
just
curious you know they're like oh i went
to the store and this person was like
hey like uh uh where'd you get that
clothes like i
want to know where it's from because
like it's you know it looks very you
know culturally like you
you can't wear it yeah like and they're
like why do they have to ask about my
culture clothes my culture is not a prop
it's like he's just
asking where you got your clothes bro
how's he supposed to know if he doesn't
ask
you know it's not like he walked up to
you was like hell whoa where are you
from you know like it's they're like
that's a underside that's like
slight racism i was like that's not even
racist because they keep saying
you know what it's not enough to not
know anymore
they should know by this time it's like
that's not how it works
some people just don't know like imagine
you're blind
right and i'm like yo check out my shirt
do you like it
what are you gonna say you can't see it
yeah no i i don't see it
yo what the [ __ ] is wrong with you yeah
why can't you see my shirt yeah like
is anger the right response or someone
who can't see
or am i gonna be like dude look at the
lines here and this design
yeah and look at these colors and you're
gonna have to explain it to them yeah
and i agree too like racism isn't just
something that's always just black and
white and there are different shades of
it
but but you have to be smart enough to
understand what sometimes it's just
curiosity and ignorance
you have to have that wherewithal
because if not you're just going to be
angry all the time yeah and you're gonna
just
you're gonna make these people grow
distant from you further and further
away and they're just never gonna know
what to say around you
and i don't like that because it doesn't
allow for free-flowing conversation
like um i talked about this example
where i was at a post office waiting in
line and somebody asked me i was like
hey man what's the best asian food in
the area
and i was i found that really hilarious
and the funny thing is i knew
yeah like i know like you're you [ __ ]
ask the right person i know
you know but in my mind i'm like
lightweight races that you would ask me
but why the [ __ ] would he ask the white
dude here yeah
you know so i'm like that makes sense
yeah like we can't
hold them like up to some [ __ ]
standard that they have no
clue like where even the starting line
starts yeah it's insane like
how could you not like when you when
you're watching uh i don't know let's
say
uh jiu-jitsu yeah you know how could
this
black belt not know or whatever yeah i'm
just like hey man he knows okay
yeah just they they need they need time
to learn this [ __ ] because they're at
blue belt or something yeah they're not
gonna know at this eighth
degree black belt level [ __ ] yeah you
know it's just easy to be angry
but hey guys that wraps up this episode
of the genius brain
podcast i hope you enjoyed uh this is
the new angle i guess
i actually like this it shows like more
of the room and stuff but um
got the artwork all the way across yeah
so it looks great but uh you can follow
uh ed
ed parkvp on instagram and you can catch
uh
genius brain every thursday and sundays
hope that made you think
hope that made you empathize and think
about your relationship with your
parents and i hope your parents isn't a
[ __ ] kong
hey love them anyway love them anyways
yeah we'll see y'all next time your
parents
peace